hey guys Lucy here with a quick gamespot
news update for you I really hope you're
not getting fed up of destiny leaks
because yes you guessed it there's been
another one the reddit user who recently
published a payload of leaked destiny
screens which have laid bare the
upcoming house of worlds expansion has
disclosed another batch of enlightening
images known by the online handle Mega
Man exe for the anonymous japan-based
destiny fan has discovered a reference
to the reef social space within the
game's files an image of the select
destination screen appears to suggest
that this will be a non combat zone
likely similar to the tower hub on earth
although Bungie has not revealed or
confirmed any details Bungie has in the
past noted that images and details that
leaked online may not be representative
of the final product for now the reef in
destiny remains an asteroid belt that
players visit for just a handful of
cutscenes how or if Bungie will expand
the reef is a matter for debate two
years ago the studio mentioned plans to
build a social hub on the level but
since then has not mentioned such plans
it is possible that the reef social
space was scrapped before Destiny's
release and the discovery of this
destination is merely a loose end
meanwhile the leaker has also published
more information on possible crucible
matches and queen of the reef missions
house of wolves will mark the second
major expansion to destiny following the
release of the dark below in December
it's expected to launch between April
and June the reddit leaker has
previously suggested that the plan
destiny house of wolves release date is
May nineteenth so which has been your
favorite destiny leak are you excited
for a new social area for the latest on
destiny and our review of the dark below
expansion make sure you head over to
gamespot com
you